Trascrizione: Alessia Tomaselli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Se mi seguirete per 10 minuti,
proverò a darvi un po’ di strumenti
che vi aiuteranno a evitare
qualche vicolo cieco.
Non sto per parlarvi di urbanistica,
la viabilità non c'entra niente:
vi sto parlando di comunicazione,
ma penso che lo abbiate capito
leggendo il titolo di questo intervento.
Perché “vicoli ciechi”,
che è l'espressione che ho scelto
quando mi hanno chiesto
di sintetizzare in poche parole
il senso del mio discorso,
è una metafora.
Una metafora è una scorciatoia
per arrivare più in fretta, e più dritti,
a comunicare un messaggio.
Nella pubblicità, che è il mio mestiere,
le scorciatoie fanno parte del gioco,
e non c'è niente male in questo:
noi abbiamo a volte
30 secondi, 20 secondi,
dieci secondi di uno spot televisivo,
o abbiamo poche righe
su un cartellone pubblicitario.
E quindi, la velocità ci serve.
Niente di male, quindi,
nell'usare scorciatoie;
ma bisogna usarle bene.
La psicologia cognitiva ci dice
che il nostro cervello
ha bisogno di scorciatoie:
è pigro il cervello, a volte.
Per cui ci sono procedimenti,
che si chiamano euristiche,
che sono dei processi mentali
che ci aiutano a prendere decisioni
molto velocemente.
Sono basate sull'intuito,
sull'esperienza accumulata:
l'esempio più classico, quello scolastico,
è quando io vedo un'auto
che viene verso di me a tutta velocità.
Non sto ad analizzare
tutti i dati a disposizione,
non sto a pensare quanto sarà la velocità,
quanta è la distanza di frenata,
l'arco per sterzare,
e nemmeno le ragioni
che dovrebbero spingere il guidatore
a voler uccidere proprio me,
venendomi addosso.
Il mio cervello, velocemente, mi dice:
“Vai, senza tante storie: vai!”.
Quella è una scorciatoia,
e in quel caso è una scorciatoia buona.
Non tutte le scorciatoie, però,
sono scorciatoie buone.
L'immagine che vedete alle mie spalle
è molto diretta, molto facile,
perché nel momento in cui io
devo indicare, in pochissimo tempo,
a un uomo o una donna,
da che parte dirigersi,
questa cosa funziona perfettamente.
Peraltro, mi viene in mente,
settimana scorsa ero a giocare
a tennis all'Isola d'Elba,
per qualche giorno soltanto.
E in spiaggia ho avuto bisogno
di andare in bagno.
Ho chiesto al ragazzo del bar
di indicarmi la strada,
sono andato diretto,
e quando sono uscito dalla porta del bagno
mi sono trovato di fronte una signora
che mi guardava malissimo,
arrabbiatissima.
Ovviamente, ho capito
di aver fatto qualche errore.
Non sapendo esattamente quale,
la prima cosa che ho fatto
fu voltarmi per guardare la targhetta.
In quel caso, non c'era un pittogramma
ma c'era una scritta:
c'era scritto “Signore”.
Ho capito l'errore,
ma con una brillantezza che, in realtà,
ha sorpreso me per primo
ho detto: “Be’, io sono un signore!”.
La signora non ha gradito tantissimo,
è rimasta arrabbiata.
Ma tornando a questo pittogramma,
fa il suo mestiere egregiamente.
Però, se ci facciamo caso,
contiene uno stereotipo -
perché la donna porta la gonna,
banalmente.
E con questo non voglio dire
che lo stereotipo è sempre negativo,
è sempre da condannare.
Perché ci sono casi, tipo questo,
in cui se io scelgo
di utilizzare un camice bianco
per dire “tecnico, esperto, medico”
sto prendendo una scorciatoia,
ma non vado in nessun vicolo cieco,
non sto facendo male a nessuno.
Quindi faccio il mio lavoro,
e lo faccio senza danni.
Se invece, come purtroppo
in pubblicità facciamo ancora,
e soprattutto abbiamo fatto,
utilizzo, per descrivere
una famiglia, degli stereotipi
che prevedono, per esempio:
il marito che torna a casa la sera,;
si toglie la giacca,
bello stanco, la cravatta;
si mette sul divano ad aspettare
che la servizievole mogliettina
gli prepari la cena,
questo è uno stereotipo
che oltre a essere un po’ ridicolo
è altamente discriminatorio,
e molto pericoloso.
È vero che il pericolo
è insito un po’ nello stereotipo,
anche nella sua etimologia:
perché stereotipo viene dal greco:
“stéreos”, che significa duro,
e “tipo”, che significa impronta.
Quindi un'impronta dura,
un'impronta indelebile:
una volta che l'ho lasciata,
faccio fatica a cancellarla,
a liberarmene.
E resto nell'antica Grecia
per parlarvi della seconda scorciatoia
di questa sera, che è la metafora.
L’abbiamo accennata
all'inizio, la metafora:
Aristotele la definiva
uno dei mezzi più potenti
per trasmettere un messaggio.
Diceva che ci sono alcuni concetti
che nessun discorso lineare e razionale
può esprimere in maniera
tanto efficace quanto una metafora.
È vero che c'è anche chi,
come il mio amico Luca Sofri,
dice che le metafore, spesso,
sono atti di pigrizia
perché utilizzano immagini preconfezionate
e quindi descrivono
una realtà preconfezionata.
È vero,
però è vero che nella pubblicità
è più la necessità
di velocità che la pigrizia,
che ci guida a scegliere le metafore.
La metafora è uno strumento potentissimo,
non è solo uno strumento veloce
ma è uno strumento potentissimo
perché funziona per analogia.
Quindi io, quando voglio
parlare di qualcosa
ne scelgo qualcos'altro.
E posso scegliere liberamente,
per esempio attingendo
nel bagaglio culturale, o nelle emozioni,
delle persone a cui sto parlando.
E questo trasforma la metafora,
da un lato, in qualcosa che arriva dritto,
e che può toccare
non solo le corde razionali
ma anche quelle emotive delle persone;
dall'altra parte lo rende
particolarmente pericoloso,
è uno strumento –
anche tanti autori la definiscono
un pericolosissimo
strumento di manipolazione.
Si può imbrogliare facilmente,
con le metafore, proprio per questo:
perché mi posso allontanare
dal concetto che voglio esprimere
e sceglierne un altro,
e creo quasi un falso sillogismo.
La terza scorciatoia
di cui parlo è l'algoritmo,
la pesco dal mondo scientifico
per evitare di fermarmi troppo
sull'antica Grecia
ed essere scambiato
per un vecchio professore di lettere.
Senza che abbia niente -
anzi, adoro i professori di lettere.
Però l'algoritmo, che è uno strumento
che a parte la matematica -
anzi, ha una definizione
abbastanza complicata,
che mi sono scritto perché questa,
a memoria, non me la ricordavo:
dice l'algoritmo è
“una strategia per la soluzione
dei problemi di uno stesso tipo
basata su un numero finito di operazioni
che strutturano percorsi
codificati e ripetibili”.
L'applicazione di un algoritmo
consente di arrivare velocemente
a soluzioni certe attraverso dati certi.
Quindi, a differenza delle euristiche,
che sono basate sull’intuito,
l'algoritmo è basato su dati certi.
Io, che non sono un matematico,
uso l'algoritmo, ad esempio,
per inseguire le persone sul web.
Vi sarà capitato migliaia di volte,
su Facebook, su Instagram,
di trovarvi di fronte
a un annuncio pubblicitario
che vi proponeva esattamente
quello che volevate,
quello che avevate in testa,
quello di cui avevate
parlato con gli amici.
In quel caso, l'algoritmo funziona bene,
è una bella scorciatoia:
perché a voi, che cercate contenuto,
fornisce -
per voi la pubblicità diventa servizio;
e per l'investitore,
che spende dei soldi
per arrivare a parlare con voi,
evita l'”effetto dispersione”,
puntando sulla rilevanza
di quel contenuto per voi.
Funziona abbastanza bene:
salvo quando, per esempio,
quel libro che davvero vi piace tanto,
però l'avete già comprato,
l'avete anche consigliato agli amici,
l’avete recensito,
siete stufi di vederlo ogni volta:
in quel caso, l'algoritmo scricchiola.
Però i vicoli ciechi dell'algoritmo
sono più legati all'uso
superficiale dell'algoritmo.
Qui c'è una slide che trovo interessante,
perché mette in correlazione
dei dati veri, certi,
e dice che il tasso di divorzi nel Maine
ha una correlazione del 99,26 percento
con il consumo di margarina
negli Stati Uniti.
Sono dati veri, e sono dati
estratti da un algoritmo
che, se lo uso superficialmente,
posso arrivare ad utilizzare per fare,
magari, una campagna tipo questa:
“Stanco della tua relazione matrimoniale?
Compra la nostra margarina!”.
Noi non ne usiamo tanta, qui in Italia;
però insomma, potrebbe essere
un bell’escamotage.
Ovviamente, è evidente
che sia qualcosa di sbagliato,
che sia un vicolo cieco
quello in cui ci porta l'algoritmo.
E ci fa anche sorridere,
vi vedo sorridere su questa campagna.
Però, io vi dico una cosa:
la gente crede alla pubblicità.
Ci crede molto, molto di più
di quanto voi possiate immaginare.
E questo dà a noi
comunicatori pubblicitari
una responsabilità enorme,
che dovremmo prenderci tutta.
La prima responsabilità
è quella di essere completamente onesti,
ma anche severamente attenti
nei messaggi che passiamo,
perché i nostri messaggi arrivano;
la seconda, in positivo, un po’ più bella,
è quella che proprio perché
i nostri messaggi arrivano,
le nostre scorciatoie funzionano,
noi possiamo anche contribuire,
nel nostro piccolo,
a rendere il mondo
un posto un po’ migliore.
Senza fare grandi cose,
magari semplicemente raccontandolo,
proponendolo, visualizzandolo in un modo -
non esattamente come lo vediamo,
ma come ci piacerebbe che fosse,
come vorremmo che fosse.
Pescando ancora dalla psicologia,
queste si chiamano profezie autoavveranti:
io descrivo un mondo come potrebbe essere
e quello, a volte, “magicamente” succede.
E poi, l'altra responsabilità
che noi comunicatori
condividiamo con tutti voi -
con voi in platea, con le persone
che ci guardano online -
è quella di stare attenti,
di imparare a riconoscere
i luoghi comuni, gli stereotipi,
capire quali fanno male,
quali creano gabbie,
sradicarle queste gabbie, non accettarle,
e non accettare di difendersi
quando sono di fronte a uno stereotipo
con la solita odiosissima frase:
“Si è sempre detto così,
si è sempre visto così.
Cosa vuoi che faccia?”
Perché altrimenti saremo noi -
e qui cito un cantautore,
e un grande comunicatore,
che è Ivano Fossati -
"saremo noi che abbiamo nella testa
un maledetto muro”.